the White House and the president have a
habit of acknowledging tragedies
killings specifically when they are
politically advantageous to them and
then ignoring them when they are not so
advantageous and we've seen this pattern
with incidents of violence committed by
Muslims which Trump is very quick and
eager to talk about compared to violence
where either Muslims are the victims or
when the violence is perpetrated by good
ol American born white dudes and the
perpetrators are not anybody that Trump
all of a sudden wants to talk about
right but there is one sort of
overarching category of violent acts
that Donald Trump has been ignoring
almost in total never mind on an event
by event basis and I'm talking about
people killed by the alt-right and/or
white supremacists more than 100 people
have been murdered or injured by the
white supremacists slash alt-right
movement and nine of these incidents
took place in 2017 during Donald Trump's
presidency and Donald Trump has not
mentioned these incidents very little
time is ever devoted to covering these
incidents by corporate media although
we've been making an effort to talk
about them and have the hundred-plus
that have been killed or injured by
alt-right nuts or white supremacist
extremists or whoever of the hundred
plus 43 have been black brown or Muslim
and not a word from Donald Trump about
them and thanks to the work of the
Southern Poverty Law Center we have data
about these incidents and from the SPL
C's report they say quote these
perpetrators were all male and with the
exception of three men all under the age
of 30 at the time they are alleged to
have killed the average age of the
alt-right killers is 26 the youngest of
17 1 Alexander Bissonnette is Canadian
but the rest are American while some
certainly displayed signs of mental
illness all share a history of consuming
and/or participating in the type of
far-right
that defines the alt-right and yet no
tweets from Trump nothing the closest he
came to talking about these types is to
say that after the Charlottesville
Fiasco where neo Nazis marched Trump
said there were fine people on both
sides including on the side of the white
supremacists and the alt rightist and I
want to add something else here alright
doesn't necessarily mean neo-nazi or
white supremacists right I already know
Pat that we're gonna get emails from
people saying David you're conflating
alright and white supremacists I'm not
there's alright and there's white
supremacists and they're not necessarily
the same thing but there is a lot of
overlap and a lot of neo-nazi and white
supremacist ideology has been sort of
rebranded successfully as alt right
through the existence of the trump
presidency and campaign earlier on and
that makes it sound way better it makes
it sound way less threatening but it's
still the same toxic vile drivel that
we're familiar with and this is part of
the bigger context of normalization of
extreme views one of the biggest effects
of the Trump candidacy and presidency
has been not policy for example although
we talk about policy not the destruction
of the reputation of the United States
around the world as a result of Trump
being in the White House although we've
talked about that as well it's been the
normalization of extreme ideas that is a
major trend of the Trump White House and
the impact of it and we've got to keep
working against that normalization
because it's happening very aggressively
and when it also becomes real-world
violence we often don't hear about it
because it's swept under the rug and not
covered at all yeah and of course all
murders and tragedies should be avoided
and yes those people should be condemned
in all cases they're all trash guard
list of if they are immigrants or
Muslims or people from the alt-right but
you see Trump picking out the specific
anecdotes that align with his worldview
that's exactly the political agenda and
he ignores the other ones and that's
that's really the problem with anecdotes
they're not statistically significant
that's exactly right that's when an
anecdote about someone coming over the
physical us-mexico border as a
justification for changing this or that
law or building a wall ignores the
statistic
reality that most people here illegally
are not actually crossing the us-mexico
Mexico border there overstaying visas
are coming in in other ways it's it's
really a shame and it really does expose
they're just totally blatant political
nature of everything that the Trump
administration has been doing